Element 41 is niobium and I'd never seen
niobium until recently. And then I was lent a metal.
I haven't won the metal,
but it is a metal that is given each year to somebody who's made a real
contribution to the field of niobium chemistry or niobium science.
The metal is made out of niobium. So look carefully.
This is metallic niobium.
I can't remember who won it last year,
but it has been won by a series of people,
mostly in the field of metallic energy.
And I'll explain why it's mortality rather than chemistry. In a minute,
I gave you that one professor, I was lent this by the, um,
company CBMM,
which awards this metal and together with the Institute
of materials and minerals, it is named after Charles Hatchett,
who was the English scientist who discovered niobium or discovered the
element initially. And it's really quite interesting.
It was at the beginning of the 19th century,
just after the idea of elements had been published.
So everybody was looking for elements and Charles Hatchett looked at a
mineral which had been in a museum in London for quite a long time,
a mineral that came from America and he discovered a new element.
And because it came from America,
he called it Columbia them because Columbia,
isn't the Latin name that is often used for America.
And I think the name Columbian sounds really beautiful.
Normally really opposed to naming elements after countries.
Well,
I think it's quite nice when it's named by somebody who doesn't come from that
country, then it's a genuine honor,
rather than a patriotic gesture. And of course,
England had just lost the American colonies. So it was particularly,
um, nice gesture.
Hatchett unfortunately didn't continue as a chemist.
And he worked in a company that made courages,
I suppose, the modern equivalent of a sports car company.
And later in his career, he focused on the carriages rather than on the science.
The element was then rediscovered in Germany and named
niobium. There was a problem because the Americans called it Columbia,
the Europeans called it niobium and there was all sorts of trade-off.
It was agreed.
The Americans would call it niobium if the Germans and the
Europeans would call Wolf from tungsten.
So everybody was happy,
but niobium is actually a relatively abandoned at
element compared to many of the metals. And the by far,
the biggest deposit is in Brazil where this
CBMM is a mining company that digs niobium out to the ground.
Now the main use for niobium at the moment is in strengthening steel
steel for making bridges steel, for making cars steel,
for making pipelines that you use for high pressure gas, like natural gas.
So imagine this piece of paper is steel.
If the steel was just a single crystal, if you put a force on it,
like my pulling here, it would be very strong,
but actually the steel consists of small
so-called grains, rather like small crystals.
The boundary between the grains is a weak point.
So let me illustrate that by tearing the paper a bit.
Now you can see if I pull again, when there's this weak point,
it just pulls apart very easily.
So the grain boundaries is what causes the failure and the
pipe bursts. If you don't make it thick enough,
if you add just a tiny bit of niobium to the steel,
less than 0.1 of a percent, less than one part in a thousand,
the niobium concentrates along the grain boundary
and strengthens it. Let me show you an analogy again.
So here we've got, uh,
two grains and you can see this weak point in between,
but now if you imagine the
niobium across this green boundary,
it forms a block so that when you pull it
it's much stronger and it doesn't break. I'm pulling really hard.
What this means is that if you add a small amount of niobium to
your pipe, to the steel that you make your pipe,
you can put a lot more gas through the same pipe.
There's a pipe in China, which is 8,000 kilometers long.
And by adding some by opium and making the pipe a little
heavier one and a quarter times heavier,
you can take two and a half times as much gas down the same pipe in
cars,
the cars in developed countries like the U S and in Europe,
they add about 200 grams of niobium to the steel that makes up
the car.
And that saves a hundred kilos of weight of steel in that car.
It's almost the weight of a whole passenger.
And so then when you're driving every hundred
kilometers or so that you drive that saves one or two liters of petrol,
depending how aggressively you drive.
Professor, how does adeno BIA make the car lighter?
Wait, it makes the car lighter because the seal steel is stronger.
So you don't need so much steel to make the same strength car.
But you said the pipe was made heavier in China. That's because of other things,
right?
Well, you made it heavier by little bit,
and then you could take twice as much gas in it, in the car.
You just want to take the same number of passengers so you can make it lighter
and take the same number of passengers.
It's quite difficult to put just a small amount of niobium
into the steel.
It's rather like adding just the grain or two. So you're cooking.
So in fact, the producers of niobium produce a material,
which is called Fera niobium,
which is a mixture of iron and niobium of which I've got some
pieces here. It looks a bit black if you crack it open.
And so this is the material that is added to the mix when people are making
steel. Well,
I believe that some just in America still call it
Colombian. And I think that's rather nice,
but it's not used as the name in chemistry.
And in fact,
I think most chemists will no longer have even know the name
existed. I liked it.
It rolls off the tongue so much nicer than some of the modern names for elements
that recently discovered ones.
But it's also good because it reminds one of the history.
And I think the discovery of niobium or Columbian
in the sample in the museum is a very good reason why we need to
preserve things in museums.
Because very often scientists who come later can
discover things that the people who originally collected the samples would never
have. Trent told the person who originally collected the sample
where now European was discovered, didn't know the elements existed.
So there was the sample just waiting for the
future scientists to discover that.
All right. Yeah.
So the other application for niobium is in the alloy with
tin, which makes so-called superconducting wire,
some wires, when you cool it down to very low temperature,
lose all their electrical resistance.
So you can put through a very big current without heating up because the heat
generated by an electric current is related to the resistance.
If the resistance is zero, no heating,
this means that you can make very small and very powerful magnets,
such a used for magnetic resonance imaging.
And for some sorts of accelerators,
like the large Hadron Collider at CERN niobium
again has a really quite important metallurgical role.
I'm not a physicist.
I'm not sure exactly why it is that niobium tin has these
superconducting properties, but they only happen at very low temperature.
So you need liquid helium to cool them right down before you see
this behavior.